[Musique]
les joueurs
depuis l'élection le dalang trappe nos
voisins américains vivent dans des
étapes lutte est uni que jamais les deux
années qui viennent de passer ont donné
lieu à des affrontements entre citoyens
de niveau rarement égalé
on dit que nous sommes en train de vivre
une sorte de guerre civile non et pierce
godwin
je suis un rouge un républicain il
décrit les migrants comme l'autre
l'étranger on est du ca déjà en
allemagne en 1939 mon nom est sous
barnett je suis une bleue une démocrate
il y à plus d'une centaine
d'organisations qui tente de recoller
les morceaux à travers les états unis la
plus importante s'appelle better angels
cette association compte 6000 adhérents
répartis dans une quarantaine d'états sa
principale activité la mise sur pieds
d'ateliers de discussion d'un jour entre
républicains et démocrates
une sorte de thérapie collective
politique mais en petits groupes pour
éviter les débordements
[Musique]
cette fois cela se passe à raleigh en
caroline du nord un état de plus de 10
millions d'habitants qui compte encore
aujourd'hui des partisans de mouvements
racistes mais ce sont plutôt les
citoyens modéré démocrates et
républicains qui assiste à ce genre
d'atelier on leur dit bien vous êtes ici
pour écouter et discuter ça pour
débattre ce message les modérateurs
doivent le répéter plusieurs fois parce
que les participants semblent vraiment
inquiet je n'ose plus parler de
politique avec les voisins on le voit de
plus en plus les gens sont vraiment très
émotif les gens disent tu es de mon côté
sinon tu es mon ennemi ça je pense que
c'est une grave erreur
pendant la journée les démocrates les
bleus et les républicains les rouges
sont invités à se regrouper d'abord
entre eux dans des salles distinctes
pour parler des préjugés à leur égard
ou encore pour formuler des questions
qui seront ensuite posées aucun adverse
quand les démocrates demandent aux
républicains des solutions pour contrer
le réchauffement climatique
les réponses sont évasives et
incomplètes même malaise pour les
démocrates
quand on leur demande s'il faut
augmenter les taxes pour financer les
universités
sans surprise les échanges portent plus
tard sur l'immigration et la frontière
avec le mexique
willie bain de sang soo et une bleue
typique
elle travaille pour le parti démocrate
aux élections elle s'oppose à toutes les
idées de dans l'autre up et s'inquiète
pour l'avenir de la planète
ces jours ci on ne parle que de la
paralysie gouvernementale
et pendant ce temps il y a des problèmes
plus graves dont on ne pas ou pas au
cours de l'atelier un républicain et un
rouge m'a dit toute cette crise c'est
une fabrication
j'ai été vraiment surprise de l'entendre
lui dire ça ancien conseiller d'une
sénatrice républicaine à washington
entrepreneur et consultant est un rouge
tout aussi typique
il croit à l'entreprise privée à la
réduction des taxes et de la taille de
l'état
nous avons maintenant tendance à nous
associer à des gens qui nous ressemblent
qui pensent comme nous qui ont le même
niveau de revenu
le même type d'emploi
et l'attitude du président antoine
contribue aussi approfondir les
divisions dans le pays
duane buck a organisé plus d'une dizaine
de rencontres du même genre au cours des
deux dernières années
ça ne rend pas pour autant optimiste sur
l'avenir du climat dans le pays
agender malheureusement c'est le
discours des plus radicaux des deux
côtés qui attire l'attention
les modérés se radicalise à leur contact
j'ai bien peur que la division ne
s'accentue encore au cours des deux
prochaines années
j'espère que better angels et autres
groupes semblables pourront contribuer à
renverser cette tendance
c'est devenu une obsession pour moi
contrer cette vague de rancoeur qui
déferle dans le pays
c'est en train de devenir une véritable
crise sociale
les mecs je ne sais pas je l'espère jose
a organisé deux 180 réunions comme celle
ci aux états unis depuis sa création au
lendemain de l'élection de dents longues
trompes des dizaines d'autres sont
prévues dans les mois prochains
leur nouveau défi à tirer des citoyens
moins modérée pendant une période qui
risque d'être encore plus polarisée
non
à